let's say that I were to walk up to you
on the street and said alright I have
this function G of X which I'm going to
define as the definite integral from 19
to X of the cube root of T DT and then I
were to ask you what is the derivative
of G evaluated at 27 pause this video
and think about how you would approach
that well the most obvious thing would
be all right G prime of X and I'll
switch colors here just for a little bit
of contrast G prime of X is going to be
the derivative with respect to X of all
of this business of all of I'll put it
in brackets here the integral from 19 to
X of the cube root of T DT and you might
be tempted to take the antiderivative
here and evaluated it X evaluated at 19
find the difference and then take the
derivative and you could do that and
then evaluate it at 27 but we are going
to see a shortcut you could just use the
fundamental theorem of calculus if
you're taking the derivative with
respect to X of a of a function that's
defined by a definite integral right
like this where our upper boundary is X
this is just going to be equal to our
inner function right over here with
instead of T being the variable it would
now be X so this is just going to be
equal to the cube root of x and that
saved us some time there but it can be
really useful if this function inside
the integral is really hard to take the
antiderivative of it's really hard to
evaluate this integral the fundamental
theorem of calculus can be very useful
and so going back to our original
question G prime of 27 well this is just
going to be equal to the cube root of 27
which of course is equal to 3 and we're
done